We asked 4 business people in India to talk about their motivation to develop applications and here is their story
India is a country of 1.3 billion people
With many segments of the population
Where income levels vary
Culture and spoken languages
Technology can create a common layer
And effectively improve people's quality of life
I think the smartphone is the best tool of our time
And we can do many things
As well as global problems
Mobile phone and Internet connection
They make everyone in one level
HealthifyM is the most famous health and fitness application in India
Using the application once daily achieves confirmed but slow results
To promote health care and lifestyle change in the country
There were no calorie measurement tools in India
Our people are the most affected by diabetes and heart disease globally
I felt it was a problem facing millions of Indians
A person must have a food database
UrbanClap is an application that helps you buy
High quality and reliable home services
Such as a beauty specialist and an interior designer
And other services
I have checked the craft system in India
The vast majority of owners of these occupations and trades
Despite their skill
Earn a monthly income ranging from 10 to 50 thousand ruby
There are multiple reasons not to make them
Able to professionally manage small business
To achieve a possible income of up to 60 thousand ruby ​​per month
And to promote engagement in the middle class in India
RailYatri is an application that helps travelers in India
Who rely on railways
To enable them to make smart decisions
We used to follow the circumstance
From a place in the country to another place in the world
Why can not we track a train going a half mile?
We know very well that people are using it
Language to handle content
If you see the readers of the newspapers
And news readers about Bollywood movies
They watch content in local languages
So we got the idea on its own
Without any market research
This was a key idea for us
And a major reason people use our application
DailyHunt is one of the most popular apps in the country
And 95% of the application's users speak non-English local languages
Currently 3 million user applications are used everywhere
About 200 trainers and nutritionists are deployed
Around the world
Application is one of the top rated applications in India
According to the monthly average, the number of users is about to reach 9 million users.
Over a period of time, we added
All tracks, hospitals, information and others
We have about 70 thousand service partners
They use our app daily
We continue to serve more than 10,000 customers a day
We aim to provide 1 million jobs in the service sector in India
I advise those who think to invent something to overcome their fear
As far as I know, there is no risk of becoming an entrepreneur
If you came up with a great idea, stick to it
You have to get out of your office
And explore India's real problems
To actually create an app
Achieves success in India.